hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast i'm your host sean carroll
long time listeners will know that we've
talked about game theory
before on the podcast usually in the
context of
literally playing games we've had no
less than two different podcasts about
playing poker
or realizing that there are lessons from
poker that you can apply
more widely and in fact i think both
times we noted that jon von neumann who
is the father of game theory
invented it in order to analyze his
local poker game
uh we also talked to frank lance who is
a game designer about game theory
but the wonderful thing about game
theory is that it applies much more
broadly than that it's a
lesson in strategic interactions between
agents with different interests right so
that's obviously
a hugely broad kind of conceptual
framework
in which to think about a whole bunch of
different issues so today we're going to
be talking to kailyn o'connor
who is a philosopher of science she has
quite a broad portfolio in terms of
research interests but one of the things
she's done
she's written a couple of books on
applying game theory
to both biological evolution thinking
about what species evolve
how they interact with each other who's
predator who's prey
how they fill different niches and so
forth and also one applying game theory
to
human behavior why do human beings treat
each other
in different ways and in particular can
we understand
the origin of certain inequities in
society
in game theoretic terms now this is a
very difficult thing to do right because
when you have an inequity in society
when
one group is discriminated against or
picked on another group
is privileged and has more wealth or
resources or power or whatever
there's probably a whole host of reasons
why and people will debate them
but game theory sort of presents an
interesting new twist on this kind of
problem imagine
that you know you're a kid and you have
a sibling
and your mom says to the two of you to
you and your sibling okay there's a pint
of ice cream here
you each tell me what fraction of the
pint of ice cream you would like to eat
and if the total that you say is less
than the whole pint of ice cream less
than or equal to it
then i will split it up according to the
rules that you just suggested
but if you suggest a total that is more
than one
right more than the whole pint then
nobody gets any ice cream
now of course the fair thing to do would
be for you and your sibling
to say i each want half of the pint of
ice cream then you would both get half
everybody's happy
but what if you know from past
experience
that your sibling is always very greedy
and they're almost guaranteed to ask for
two-thirds of the pint of ice cream
okay so you could stubbornly ask for
your half
because that's the fair thing but then
neither one of you get anything
you are both worse off okay so because
your sibling
is going to have this strategy and you
know it
in a strictly utilitarian sense it makes
sense for you to only ask for a third
of the ice cream so you can see how by
this kind of analysis
inequities creep into the system even
though the
there's no difference between the two
players of the game
initially so i find this all extremely
fascinating it's sort of a
completely different lens with which we
can use to analyze
biology psychology sociology a whole
bunch of interesting things it's nowhere
near the whole story
in any of these cases but different
angles different perspectives are always
very welcome so i think you're going to
find this conversation very interesting
the other announcement to make of course
is that for those of you who've been
following along you know
i have this video series called the
biggest ideas in the universe
and we're done we have reached the
conclusion last week was the last
video uh there were 24 different ideas
the last idea
was science that was a bit more
philosophical and meta the other ideas
are things like space
time matter gravity you know stuff like
that physics ideas physics
and cosmology ideas we had some
off-the-wall ones we did emergence and
renormalization
and uh criticality and complexity but
anyway they're all done there's one
every week there's one video and one q a
video you can
find them all on my youtube channel i do
have a youtube channel
it's youtube.com sean carroll there's no
m
in there uh like patreon supporters or
twitter followers
might know about uh sean m carroll's
what i usually use but for some reason
on youtube it's just sean carroll anyway
if you haven't checked them out i
encourage you to check out the videos if
you're interested in physics
you get to see me as well as listen to
me although
yeah in fact since i'm drawing and
writing equations in most of these
videos i think that the visual
aspect of it is actually important um
you could also see
my improvement as a videographer and
cinematographer over time
as i figure out how to do the green
screen and so forth and you can also see
that i never
improve all the way i was still making
pretty elementary mistakes
in my uh video skill package as time
went on but it was a lot of fun
uh we got a lot of viewers which which
warms my heart and it's always good to
see that people are interested in
learning new things
about the universe so with that let's go
caleb o'connor welcome to the minds gate
podcast oh well thank you so much for
having me sean
so we've talked to philosophers before
we've talked to biologists i i'm trying
to think i'm not sure that i've really
done any
philosophy of biology is that is that
fair to
as a way to characterize what we're
going to talk about today
yeah i think a lot of what we're going
to talk about would fall under that we
also might call some of it
like philosophy of social science um
yeah i mean philosophy of biology is
this nice
interdisciplinary area where some people
in it do things that look a lot like
theoretical biology and some people
do things that are asking more
meta-level questions about the
biological sciences you know what are
the concepts that we use in biology what
do they really mean
what can the methods in biology really
tell us or not tell us
uh so yeah and game theory is something
that i
i don't know why but like in the past
year of my life i just keep running into
it in different
uh circumstances you're not the only
podcast guest who will talk about game
theory a little bit with us
so how does well let's even before we
relate to biology why don't you tell us
in your brain what uh
how you think about what game theory is
and what it's good for
okay so i mean like little history game
theory was really introduced
sort of in the starting off in the 1940s
and 50s
and it's a branch of mathematics where
the goal is to look at strategic
interactions
and by strategic interaction i just mean
an interaction where you have
multiple actors who have some kind of
interest so these could be humans but
they also could be animals or even
something like trees or bacteria
and they interact with each other and it
matters to them what the
other actors are doing so it's the
branch of math that
you know tries to represent and tackle
this kind
of interaction and the way
you do it is by building what's called a
game so this is a sort of simple
mathematical model of a strategic
interaction
and then analyzing that game to try to
ask
can it help us predict what certain
actors would do when they're in a
strategic scenario or can it help
explain
behaviors that we see in the real world
either in humans or
in the biological world and and one of
the big ideas here is that we can
truly exactly quantify the rewards for
what we do right like
one of the buy-ins for using game theory
for anything is to say
if you do this strategy and your
opponent does some other strategy
then here's the rewards that you each
get yeah and i think
you know the way you want to think about
this is that people using game theory
don't assume that we can exactly
quantify what are the real rewards that
say
you and i would get if we manage to
coordinate some behavior if we manage to
meet each other at the right time for
coffee i mean it'd be hard to quantify
like is this a psychological thing you
know and how much pleasure do we get or
you know what material goods do we get
but rather the idea is we can
use specific numbers to represent those
rewards
and then by making them precise we can
get
a kind of good enough or approximate
representation that we can also
analyze and better understand yeah i
think that's pretty fair although you
know
this is going to be one of those things
when we start applying it to biology and
to psychology and to sociology where
people are going to
poke at it in different ways when you
reach conclusions they don't want to
reach right so
maybe one of the pokes is you know are
we overly
rigorizing things that are a little bit
fundamentally fuzzy
yeah there's always this risk with
modeling i mean
modeling can be so useful and that it
allows you to make these really precise
structures
that you can analyze precisely and say
very concrete things about them
and all be talking about the exact same
thing of course
the downside to that is that you're
going to lose some of the precision of
the real world or you might represent it
incorrectly in some really significant
way
and so there are always going to be
these deep questions about is your model
the right model
is the conclusion you draw from it going
to be supported in a more complex
reality
that's okay as a physicist i'm very very
used to you know overly
idealizing complex situations into very
simple
little models we're used to that part so
why don't you i mean there's some famous
games right there's the prisoner's
dilemma i mean we're not thinking even
though you could
we're not really thinking about
backgammon or basketball or things like
that but
those are you know those are more
advanced games the little games that
we're analyzing here
are basically have these reward tables
so why don't you fill us in on how we
should be
what is the mental image we should be
having when we're playing these games
well i should note that when von neumann
was first inventing game theory he did i
think one of his first papers was called
the theory of parlor games so he did
have some kind of real games in mind
but the games you see in game theory
they're not the fun kind
in fact i teach a class called
evolutionary game theory and i sometimes
start the class being like if you're
here
because you like playing games scoot on
out like this
isn't the points for you no twister here
no twister
it's not gonna be world of warcraft or
starcraft uh
so okay a game in this sense i mean you
can define it using
four elements so the first thing is
the players who is involved in this
strategic scenario
the second thing is their possible
strategies what things
can those players do what actions you
might say
the third thing is their payoffs so
given some
combination of strategies chosen by the
players or actions that they do
what are the kind of benefits or
detriments to them
and then information is the last thing
that helps define a game
and information is approximately what do
the players know about what they're
doing so what do they know
about the setup of the strategic
scenario they're in and what do they
know
about the other opponents or players
they're involved with
so chess is a game of complete
information because you see the board
but poker you don't see the other
person's cards right right and we can
think of lots of different
kind of strategic scenarios where you
might have more or less information
so if you're bargaining with someone
that's a strategic scenario
and you might know uh you know what's
going to happen to this person if your
bargain fails or you might not know that
and knowing or not knowing might really
shift how you bargain so if you know
that this person
doesn't have anything else to do if this
bargain doesn't work they'll be in a
really bad situation you might be a more
aggressive bargainer on the basis of
that knowledge
i guess it's probably i mean you should
tell me but it's probably worth doing
the prisoner's dilemma in some detail
just because it's a wonderful example of
some of the concepts that that appear
but also some of the counter-intuitive
conclusions you can reach by taking this
seriously
yeah so the prisoner's dilemma is the
most
famous and widely analyzed game in game
theory
um because you're right it is a kind of
fascinating
little game so you assume you have two
players and you assume there's two
things that each of them
can do and people often call these two
strategies cooperate or defect
um so i'll tell the little kind of story
people like to tell about the prisoner's
dilemma
it's like you've got two prisoners and
they're each told well you can either
rat on the other one
or stay silent so staying silent would
be cooperating and ratting would be
defecting
and then the idea is okay if they
both stay silent they're going to have a
really short jail term let's say they'll
be in jail for a month
um if they both rat the other one out
they'll have a slightly longer jail term
maybe they'll be in jail for three
months
if one of them rats the other one and
that one stays silent though the one who
rats is gonna go
free and then the one who stays silent
will have a very long jail term they'll
get blamed for everything so maybe
they'll be in jail for a year
so those uh that kind of creates the
payoffs of this game
and the basic payoff structure which you
get out of this little story
is that the very best thing for anyone
is to be the one who ratted while the
other person stayed silent
but you still prefer to both stay silent
than to both rat so basically there's a
payoff structure that
incentivizes you to defect but creates a
situation where if you both defected you
would prefer that you had both
cooperated
so that's the dilemma of the game that
it's individually rational to choose to
defect
but from a kind of social level you can
all do better by not all defecting
and i guess so one of the things that
leads to a voluminous literature for
this very very simple game
to to state is that you can imagine
either
this was truly just a once-off you play
the game and in that case
i i i think that just defecting is the
right thing to do
but you could also imagine that you're
just faced with situations like this
over and over again
where maybe some cooperation would help
you out in the long term
i think the heart of why people are so
interested in this game is that in the
end
it's an analysis of altruism so if you
cooperate in the prisoner's dilemma
you've done something that will lower
your payoff
but increase the payoff of the other
player so you've done something kind of
materially inherently altruistic
and we see humans and animals in the
biological world do altruistic things
all the time
even though the kind of basic structure
of the game tells you
that's not individually rational it's
not rational to harm yourself
so the question is well if that's not
individually rational why do we see so
much altruism
and then there are a few answers one is
the one you just brought up
that were in repeated interactions with
others and that really actually changes
the structure of the game
once you start meeting the same
individuals again and again
for this kind of interaction it can
change what's rational it can make it
rational now to cooperate on the
assumption that
cooperating now will get them to
cooperate with you later
um and then there's other things like
you know
if you're looking from a biological
perspective
um you can see that being altruistic
with your kin
can end up being selected for so the
genes that would make you altruistic
with kin can be selected
basically because when you're altruistic
toward your kin you're being altruistic
towards people who are
often other altruists or actors that are
other altruists
and so altruists are getting these kind
of benefits by dint of associating with
each other
that then defectors aren't getting um so
i think that is really the heart of why
the prisoner's dilemma is so fascinating
is it
helps us answer these questions about
altruism
i bet you didn't know that september is
national life insurance awareness
month a lot of people are probably aware
of the existence of the idea of life
insurance
but they haven't quite gotten around to
doing their responsible thing and
looking into getting it for themselves
that's where policy genius comes in
policy genius is an easy to use
insurance marketplace built and backed
by a team of industry experts
that makes the whole process a snap you
head to policygenius.com in minutes
you can work out how much coverage you
need and you can compare
quotes from top insurers to find the
best price
apply for that price and then the policy
genius team handles all the paperwork
and all the red tape
policy genius works for you not for the
insurance company so if you hit any
speed bumps during the application
process
they will take care of everything they
even have policies which allow eligible
customers
to skip the in-person medical exam and
do it all over the phone
so if you need life insurance head to
policy policygenies.com right now to get
started
you could save fifteen hundred dollars a
year or more by comparing quotes at
their marketplace
policy genius when it comes to insurance
it's nice to get it right
it also i mean the the last point that
you just raised sort of brings up
questions of the selfish gene or
levels of selection kind of thing right
if i'm altruistic toward my kin
in some sense i'm being altruistic
toward my genome right i'm helping it
survive is that is it that a valid way
of thinking
yeah so i mean the way you'd think of it
is you know
from an individual perspective altruism
might not look rational you know why
would i
do something for my kin that's gonna you
know essentially make them more likely
to have more offspring and me less
likely to have more offspring
but then if you flip to the gene's eye
view so this was an idea
you know largely popularized by richard
dawkins
from a jean's eye view if you know we're
i'm a little altruistic gene
i would like to benefit other genes just
like me that it's you know the sort of
that the altruistic gene
is the point of view we look at it makes
complete sense
and yeah and so are you gonna are you
gonna come down on which is right or are
they all right or
different circumstances call for
different ways of thinking
um between what oh between perspectives
yeah yeah i you know i tend to be the
yeah different circumstances require
different kinds of thinking
type of person when it comes to um
thinking about evolution
it gets very heated you know these
arguments between uh
what levels of selection are valid
especially group selection i know is
extremely uh
controversial in different circles yeah
group selection is very controversial i
mean for people who don't know what
group selection is
it relates to the idea that um
you know in some cases you wouldn't want
to think of selection as happening
on the unit of an individual but of a
social group
that maybe if a whole social group does
well
by having certain traits that can
explain why we have
those traits now this debate
has really used a lot of game theory so
john maynard smith
did these very influential models um you
know game theoretic models where
he showed that it's quite hard to get
group selection of a certain
type to work and that's group selection
for altruism so a lot of people thought
well maybe because altruism is good on a
group level
that's why we see it groups that are
altruistic tend to be selected
he showed um that that it's hard to get
an altruistic group to be selected
um now and so a lot of people sort of
took that
criticism and variations of that to
imply that group selection
is an important period but i think
there's just sort of a confusion in the
literature where people have shown group
selection probably isn't the most
important explanation of altruism
but that doesn't show that group
selection isn't important
for the explanation of other kinds of
traits necessarily
okay okay i mean that that does make
sense and it is a bit of a
sorry distraction i got off on it
because i know that people people really
care about this so we should you know
bring it if we bring it up we should say
something about it but let's let's just
do a little bit
of the uh lingo that is used in this
game theory context so you mentioned the
prisoner's dilemma
maybe it's worth explaining what a nash
equilibrium is and i don't know if you
also
want to give other examples of games
like the prisoner's dilemma is not the
only game that uh
models actual dynamics for sure
um so nash equilibria so i mean
in game theory you build a game you get
this model of a strategic scenario and
then the next thing you do is analyze it
and what people do is apply what are
called solution concepts
to the game there are a bunch of
solution concepts but the most widely
used one is the nash equilibrium
and the idea is you're looking for sets
of strategies
where when actors are playing them none
of the actors want to change and do
something else there's no incentive
for them to switch strategies and those
sets of strategies are nash equilibria
the reason that this is an important
solution concept
is that if you are at a nash equilibria
no one wants to switch
it's approximately a stable set of
behaviors
and so that means the nash equilibria
predict
what actors will do in games and there
has been
i mean laboratory experiments don't
always confirm that people do not
play nash equilibria but they often play
them or something
like them when you have them actually
play games
um so that that's why those are so
important and if you're doing a game
theoretical analysis the first thing you
do is build
your game whatever model you're looking
at and then the next thing usually is
calculate the nash equilibria of the
game see what they tell you
so for example in the prisoner's dilemma
the issue is that
the best for both players
is to cooperate but the nash equilibrium
is they both defect right
right they do better individually i mean
the the equilibrium
relies on the fact that they're making
their decisions
individually yeah so
right that's exactly it defect effect is
the only nash equilibrium of the game
and so that's the kind of prediction for
what
rational agents would do but then
there's this benefit to not playing
the nash equilibrium in that game like
just a straightforward benefit to
everyone playing
so you mentioned um
other games i mean there's so many other
fascinating games i actually
don't work really with the nash or sorry
with the prisoner's dilemma myself
because it's been so
analyzed you're just everyone has done
everything you can imagine to the
prisoner's dilemma
and to me um situations having to do
with coordination are really fascinating
so i've done a lot of work more on
coordination
type scenarios and these are scenarios
where there's
common interest between the players and
and what i mean by that
is that they're going to get shared
payoffs
and in coordination games the way they
get shared payoffs is by somehow
coordinating behavior
but then the kind of thing that makes
the game interesting is that there are
multiple ways to coordinate behavior and
the question is
how are the actors going to settle on
one way or another
how are they going to solve what's
called a coordination problem and learn
to make their behavior work together and
this is especially interesting when we
look
at more of a societal level how does a
whole society come to learn to
coordinate
and then under that umbrella are what
are called bargaining games
which have to do with resource division
or splitting stuff
and the reason these games are so
interesting to me is that humans are in
situations all the time where they're
dividing resources whether it's
literal resources like money for your
salary
or whether it's time and effort so for
example if you're an academic on a joint
project everyone you know to get it done
you have to somehow divide the work
necessary to be done and that's a
bargain
and that it takes a type of coordination
too and so that's another set of games
that i've been really interested in
is there some kind of classification
scheme for at least all two-person games
i mean there are names to different
games and
games get a name based on the kind of
ordering of the payoffs and what that
means
for the equilibria of the game so the
prisoner's dilemma is always going to
have this structure that we've described
where there's
a strategy that's rational to take it
always benefits you
but will get lower payoffs for both
actors than the other strategy
a coordination game will have at least
two strategies maybe more
and a kind of situation where if actors
manage to match their strategies in the
right way they get better payoffs than
if they don't manage to match their
strategies in the right way
so i mean maybe an explicit example
would be helpful uh is the is the stag
hair game
an example um it's a kind of
coordination game
that you pick rather than suggesting yes
i'll just give you a totally
like here's the basic coordination game
you have two strategies
maybe it's a and b and let's say these
represent driving on the right side of
the road
and the left side of the road and you
get payoffs if you both pick a
which is both driving on the right side
you get good payoffs if you both pick b
which is both driving on the left side
but if one of you picks a and one picks
b
you don't get good payoffs because you
crash into each other
so there's a super simple example and a
physicist would say it's an example of
spontaneous symmetry breaking because it
didn't matter whether we picked left or
right
right but we but picking the same one
for everybody is definitely advantageous
right exactly and so you can ask you
know
why in certain societies or how do we
break this symmetry
and come to different conventions where
we all do something that
helps us coordinate our behavior but
ultimately it could have been something
else there are lots of other things we
can do in some situations
in this case there's just two options
but if we look at say what time
we start work in the morning there's
actually a lot of options we might have
had
and societies have to somehow come to a
convention about when they're going to
do that
if they're going to coordinate things
like when is daycare open
when are restaurants open for lunch well
back you know
back when daycare and restaurants yeah
we imagine
so look they're going to be listening to
this podcast a hundred years from now so
we gotta
speak in universal terms oh yeah i
probably yeah
yeah they might not be restaurants
anymore but for different reasons
um and i mean so but you mentioned like
when you talk about
the times that we start working or the
times that we have dinner uh there's
clearly uh coordination going on and
different societies answer that question
differently i mean this is probably
leaping ahead a little bit but how much
do we actually compare to data
uh in this field i mean we build a model
based on imagining a certain dynamics
arise from certain games and then we
test it again empirically it really
depends what you're trying to do with
the model
and so i think this is a big picture
thing
that i i'm always trying to convince
people about models
a lot of people will look at simplified
models like games or game theoretic
models and say well this is so simple
what can you even do with this what can
it tell us about the real world
i mean i think the answer totally has to
do with
what are you doing with it what are you
trying to find out about how
are you using it what inferences are you
making on the basis of it
and then you also see that depending on
what kinds of scientific inferences
people are trying to make what they're
investigating they use games very
differently
so sometimes people will build models
and compare them to data sets of what
real humans do
sometimes people will look at a human
behavior like the fact
that say everyone in india drives on the
left side of the road
and everyone in canada on the right side
and say like okay well can we explain
this
cross-cultural diversity but
inter-country regularity well maybe we
can use coordination games to
improve our understanding of patterns
like that and in that case you would be
not comparing specifically to a very
detailed data set but essentially
looking at
some empirical phenomena and then you
know making some comparison between what
you see
from the model and that and then
sometimes people use games
to do um almost kind of proof of
possibility modeling you know someone
will say
it's impossible that x and someone else
will say well no i can build
a game theoretic model that shows that
is perfectly possible
so to give an example from philosophy
you know there's this tradition of
natural language
skepticism um quine was someone in this
tradition
who argued uh you can't evolve
language naturally basically the idea
being like if you want to have a
convention for language
you need language to establish it to
tell each other
okay well tree is gonna mean tree um
but modeling work by david lewis and
then
brian skirm showed that well no you can
you can have extremely simple agents
learn how to coordinate on a signal to
mean something
without needing any sort of prior
language so that's
modeling where you're just showing a
proof of possibility when someone has
made an impossibility claim
so yeah does that make sense i mean it's
used in very different ways
and has very different connections to
data across different cases
yeah actually i think it makes perfect
sense i mean in some ways um
there's a sort of the model building
aspect for some particular empirical
phenomenon you're trying to understand
but there's also just the
theoretical aspect of understanding what
it means to be rational like you might
say like well there's no rational way to
do this but then when you
dig into the details of people playing
by the rules of this game you see some
emergent phenomenon that you might not
have guessed
yeah and i also here's another one like
another role
that i think often game theory can play
you're looking at certain cultural
patterns and you're trying to reason
about them and then
sometimes it plays a role as like an aid
to reasoning
it's not that you're doing something
much different than you would be doing
just thinking about okay what do i see
in the data empirically that humans are
doing
but it kind of helps you organize your
thoughts so i think of christina
bikieri's work
on norms which uses a lot of game theory
as falling
under that kind of category it's not
that she's doing
these like super complicated analyses
but she's saying like okay well what if
we
used a game to think about norms this
way and what if we
um thought of norms as changing the
payoffs of the game in that way
um so that's like kind of another way
you can use games
right and in particular we can so let's
i don't there's just so much to talk
about here i'm sort of tongue-tied about
it but
we did say we're going to talk about
evolution so like what is the particular
way
that a an evolutionary biologist would
think about the evolution of different
traits using this kind of game theory
uh uh technology yeah good
and so this really starts to get into
the area that i work in more which is
called evolutionary game theory and it's
it's related to other kinds of
evolutionary modeling
so this area really started
taking off in biology uh in large part
like due to the work of john maynard
smith
and the idea was something like this
okay we have these games they're
representing strategic scenarios
mostly the way people had been analyzing
games up to that point
was like assuming okay the actors
involved are rational or semi-rational
they're going to sit down they're going
to engage in some kind of deliberative
process and then decide what strategies
they're going to play or what actions
they're going to take
and biologists thought well we have
animals
organisms of all sorts engaged in
strategic interactions all across the
biological world i mean
they're bargaining with each other
they're coordinating with each other
they're signaling to each other they're
behaving altruistically pro-socially
non-pro-socially
but most of them we know aren't sitting
down and engaging in a rational
deliberation
instead a lot of their behaviors have
evolved and so the idea behind
evolutionary game theory
is you instead take a population of
agents
you assume they have certain behaviors
that they might play in a game
so maybe some of them are altruists and
some are
non-altruists or whatever it is and then
you ask
how does this group evolve and can that
explain things about strategic behavior
in the biological world and so i know
that um
in individual games of incomplete
information like poker or even just like
a sport out there on the field where you
don't know what the other player is
going to do
mixed strategies are often the best ones
to use where you have
a certain percentage of the time you do
one thing a certain percentage you do
the other but in
i presume that in a complete information
game
there's something that you should be
doing but then you when you introduce
the population idea does it become again
something where the equilibria are more
subtle where
a certain fraction of the population
does one thing and a certain other
fraction does another thing
even though they're both you know it's
clear that one is
overall better but it's also better that
there's a dispersal of strategies
it can depend on the situation so first
of all i'll point out that sometimes
when you have games with complete
information it's still best to mix up
your strategies
so if you look at rock paper scissors
even though everyone knows exactly
everything about how that game works
your best thing is to randomly mix among
your strategies fair enough yes
that's true so i'll just point that out
and then um
oh sorry what was the i'm just asking is
there analogy between that incomplete
information
and the population dynamics so that you
get the equivalent of a mixed strategy
in the sense of different members of the
population doing different things
all right that so it we're sort of like
diving this is
like the general introduction that we're
diving into like really
um that's why we're more theoretical
stuff
so um right so when you're looking at
individual behaviors you have these
mixed strategies where
sometimes the best thing to do is
sometimes do one thing and sometimes do
the other thing and that can kind of
confuse your opponent or make it
impossible for them to predict what
you're going to do and then force them
to behave in certain ways
now in biological populations you can
have an equivalent of that
which can work in different ways so one
thing is that you might have
part of the population that behaves one
way all the time and then another part
that behaves
another way but all the time and so
that's
a kind of thing where everyone has a set
behavior or strategy
but there's a mixture or variation if
you look across
the whole population then you could have
another situation which is that
everyone kind of learns to have some
mixed types of behavior
or many individuals end up having some
mix or sorry evolve to have some kind of
mixed behavior
so for example escape behavior is often
quite stochastic i mean the um
you know the bunny doesn't run right all
the time or left all the time
they mix right and so it's not that
there are some right bunnies and some
left bunnies
that all the bunnies have some
randomness in their strategy
let me pause for a second to talk about
the peloton bike if you want to keep
your mind
sharp keeping your body in good shape is
part of the process
but if you're like me it can be very
difficult to either find time
or somehow work it into a schedule with
so many other things to do
that's why peloton is so great the bike
is always there
it's in your house when you feel the
spirit move you you can hop
on it but you also get the structure of
guided classes if that's what you want
you can join
live classes throughout the day or
choose from thousands of on-demand
classes for a truly
immersive experience you can filter what
classes you want by your music
preference by the class type
the length intensity you can find your
favorite instructors and keep going back
and now new riders get to experience
peloton with a 30-day home trial
if you decide it's not for you within
those 30 days they will come pick it up
and you will get a full
refund so experience game changing
cardio with the peloton bike
visit one peloton.com to learn more
that's
e l o-n-e-p-e-l-o t o n dot com
i guess that what i have in mind is
something like uh you know about richard
lenski's long-term evolution experiment
uh i don't know is this the one where
they keep doing the
bacteria yeah they have these bacteria
and they just you know breed them in
generations and generations and
generations and generations and like
throw away most of them at every step
but keep a certain fraction
and what they found and it's in exactly
the same you know
culture whatever it is uh food source
that they have
and uh some small fraction of the
bacteria
evolved a way to eat
uh a different kind of sugar than the
other bacteria did and what was
interesting was that the
this new strain you know the the sugar
that they were eating was
less efficient it was less good as a
food source but of course there was also
less competition for it since all the
other bacteria were eating something
else and i'm
wondering if there's a game theoretic
explanation for that well so i don't
think that would probably be best
um handled using a game and the reason
well
i mean so usually when you're thinking
about a game you're thinking about
write an interaction between two
organisms where they have different
choices and they care what the other one
does
this probably you'd want to use a model
that was less game theoretic
and more about utilizing underused
resources
if you wanted to think about this kind
of scenario
okay so i guess yeah so there's
limitations on how far the the game
theoretic paradigm works here i mean
maybe you could sort of force it in by
saying that
the there's two strategies eat this
molecule or eat that molecule or
something like that but uh
yeah and that the whole population would
want to have a mixture but
yeah i think it's not it's not a sort of
paradigm case where you'd want to
where game theory would be like the best
way to go to represent that population i
don't think if it's like the rest of
science i'm sure that the game theorists
just think that they should just use
game theory for everything right like
we hammer an awful lot of nails with the
game
hammer whether or not it's the best way
for sure
so the other terminology i want to get
on the table was that of an
evolutionarily
stable strategy so this is related to
but not the same as the nash equilibrium
for these games
yeah there are formal relationships so
this is um
kind of a solution concept for an
evolving population
and the idea is to ask all right if we
have what strategies
where sorry what are the strategies
where if the whole population is playing
that strategy it's stable
to invasion by other strategies so if we
introduced
a little mutant who was doing something
else would this population still be
stable would that mutant die off
and so there's a set of conditions that
you can ask about
payoffs that will tell you whether a
certain strategy is evolutionarily
stable
so things like does it do better against
itself than other things do against
it if so it's going to be stable because
other variants or mutants
are going to die off when they enter the
population because they just won't do as
well against this kind of dominant
strategy that exists
or if mutants do kind of equally well
against the existing strategy
how do the mutants do against themselves
versus the kind of dominant strategy
and so you can you can analyze whether
strategy is evolutionary st
evolutionarily stable by asking
questions about these relationships
between the payoffs that different
strategies get
is it this might be asking too much but
is it possible to give an example
of where the nash equilibria are or are
not evolutionarily stable
um yes so oh god i don't want to
i i'm okay there are there are like
conditions that one could accurately say
about the relationship between these but
i don't want to say it and mess it up
right it's the kind of thing i always
look up on wikipedia every time
uh but i'll give you an example where
the nash equilibrium
is the evolutionarily stable strategy
um just the prisoner's dilemma in a
totally basic
population is also the evolutionarily
stable strategy so
if you have a population without adding
extra bells and whistles it will just
evolve to always all defectors
and because we can just easily see that
because if if somehow they manage to
coordinate and all become cooperators
they're doing better off but one
defector wanders into the room
and individually does better off and
then everyone goes huh defecting might
be better after all or something like
that
right or the defectors you know in the
kind of biological situation would start
to have more offspring
yeah okay well i guess good maybe we
should be more specific about that
um how do we reconcile or
marry the the usual way of thinking
about um
evolution where we have like fitness and
replication rates and survival rates
to the game theory lingo in this way
so i'm gonna pull this apart into two
things
so when we're looking at evolutionary
game theory some models are really
thinking about evolution by natural
selection and representing that
and so the idea is you have these actors
engaged in strategic scenarios
and then the payoff they get is some
kind of benefit that allows them to have
more offspring
on average and so you say okay next
generation
the ones who did well in these strategic
interactions are going to have more
offspring there's going to be more
of that kind of behavior in the
population and so that will determine a
kind of evolutionary trajectory
towards increasing like increasing the
prevalence of
strategies that do well now
people also use evolutionary models to
think about cultural evolution
and even kind of individual learning
within a lifetime
and there you're making slightly
different assumptions
but your assumption might be something
like this um there are different
possible driving behaviors some people
might
try out the right side or the left side
and we'd want to be thinking about like
way back when cars or
oh probably actually earlier wagons or
horses
were first being used on roads so people
might be trying different directions
and people might learn that okay when i
go to the right
that tends to do better for me and so
i'm gonna stick with that behavior more
often so i might learn based on the
environment that i'm in to kind of go
with one strategic
situation so i'm not like literally
having offspring
who go on the right side of the road i'm
learning and then i might be passing
that learning on to say my offspring or
my friends so there might be some kind
of
cultural transmission or imitation of
successful behaviors
well yeah but so this is important
because in the real world um
in the at least in the cultural world we
can not only
sort of see the situation we're in and
try to optimize for whatever reward we
want but we can also
talk to people we can we can signal
right and so
part of the fun of this uh approach to
evolution
is talking about the emergence of
signaling and cooperation and things
like that
yeah yeah exactly right i mean is it is
it
do we talk about sort of the robustness
of how
certain signals develop and it's it's
useful and then you can start
saying well what if someone starts lying
and or being deceitful somehow
yeah so um i mean this is sort of
so in the the book that prompted
this discussion games in the philosophy
of biology i start
basically the first half of it covers
signaling behaviors of different sorts
and especially the evolution of
signaling behaviors as they've been
analyzed by philosophers of biology and
different
biologists now
sometimes you can apply these models to
like human
language though you have to be very
careful because they're really pretty
simplified models to think about
the complexities of language so you want
to apply them to think about certain
particular aspects of language more
often
uh people are applying them to think
about signaling in the biological world
like
the peacock tail or the um
uh large jumps of the antelope when they
see a predator
and things like that right and so
does it work do we think that the
understanding of why
i mean there's a lot of goofy things out
there in the natural world in terms of
uh
things that look like tremendous wastes
of energy and resources but
that we think of as serving the purpose
of sending signals
is that something that game theory has
explicated for us or is it sort of
an aspiration or are we skeptical yeah
it has well i mean so
usually you want to break up this
literature on game theory and signaling
approximately into two big camps and one
is common interest signaling
signals when the two individuals
involved kind of want the same thing
so this might be like you know my
husband
is at the beach and he wants me to come
and like bring some stuff to the beach
and we're talking on the phone and i say
well how's the weather and he says it's
really sunny and i'm like okay and then
i pack
a big sun umbrella um so we both want
the same thing we want the right items
there at the beach
so that would be like a common interest
type of scenario
a conflict of interest type scenario is
the sort of other
area that you want to separate off where
the sender and the receiver of
information may or may not
have the exact same interest so a kind
of classic case from economics
has to do with hiring in the job market
where
you know a company is trying to hire the
best candidates but every candidate
wants to be hired
so some candidates have interests that
line up with the company they both like
for that person
to be hired but some candidates don't
they might not be a very good candidate
but they still want to get hired
and so we break signaling up into
approximately these two different camps
and then we can explain and understand
an awful lot of things
in human social world and the biological
world
using models in these two areas so if
you think about the common interest
models
they really make clear why signaling
is going on basically all the time i
mean
every i shouldn't say every organism i
don't know but stuff all the way down
to little tiny bacteria and yeasts and
plants and of course insects and
um you know all the little wiggly stuff
in the sea
are signaling to each other and
the reason is that there are all these
benefits to being able to coordinate
your action and often the only way to do
it is to somehow send information
between organisms and then there are you
know there's lots of more details of how
we can use these models to think about
the different ways that we all engage in
common interest signaling
and then this other area the conflict of
interest signaling
helps explain some of the stuff that you
were just talking about
why do we see these tremendously weird
seeming adaptations like really long
tails or
i mean if you ever look at the face of a
turkey it's just
a mess i mean like this weird blue
goo thing all over its face and neck
like why
um or uh you know
um why do mantis shrimp
have 16 different kinds of cones to see
a bajillion colors presumably
um we can help use help explain a lot of
those things using conflict of interest
signaling theory
and this does seem like a a field that
is potentially
ripe for um just so stories right i mean
so you can come up with an explanation
based on game theory for this or that
weird behavior but then
how do you know if it's the right one i
mean how do we test these ideas
right well i mean game theory is in part
the answer to how we know i mean
in many ways evolutionary modeling
including evolutionary game theory
helped throw out a lot of just so
stories in biology
and provide at least some sort of way to
constrain
what sorts of stories or narratives
people could tell about the evolution of
certain traits
so going back to group selection you
know before
this work on group selection and
altruism a lot of people would say oh
well they'd say things like the reason
we have senescence you know death
of organisms before they had to die um
is
so that the younger birds can live their
lives and have
more you know food or whatever um
and so that's a very speculative
narrative if you actually
take a model and sort of put numbers on
what are the benefits
to birds from dying young and dying old
and how might that translate into
offspring
you have a way to think more rigorously
about evolutionary processes is it also
possible then
to um sort of discuss i don't know what
the word is
some sort of uh fragmentation of
populations into different groups where
some groups say well we're going to have
one strategy and we're going to
cooperate with each other and
we're going to signal to each other so
we know whether or not you're in the
group
yeah so we do see that kind of thing
happening
um especially i would say
in human groups so fragmentation or
speciation can happen for different
reasons so one can be that you're just
in different locations right that these
organisms are over on an island
and then they might evolve to have
different behaviors than these ones over
on the mainland
as a kind of accident of history or
as you're pointing out sometimes you can
have situations where
you can have some kind of signal of
in-group membership
that identifies members of a population
and gets them to treat
their own group differently than another
group and people sometimes think that's
a way to think about in-group signaling
in human groups you know
um that different cultures or
different tribes or whatever might dress
in different ways engage in different
sorts of behaviors
and that would be used as really
relevant information about how you're
going to interact strategically with
someone
who displays in a certain way yeah i
mean let's just
boldly hop right from biology to
human beings and how they deal with each
other i mean i've heard it claimed
that signaling plays a much more
important role in human behavior even
than
we might guess like the only reason
people go to college is to signal some
achievement or the only people
recent people wear the right clothes or
go to the right movies or whatever
you know do you think that's is that
something we can analyze game
theoretically
yeah well so i'm guessing these claims
really relate to this literature i was
mentioning
on conflict of interest signaling so
there's this famous paper there looking
at
job seekers where okay they say let's
suppose they're kind of high quality
candidates and low quality candidates
for jobs
and the company wants to identify the
high
quality candidates but how can they do
that given that everyone's going to
portray themselves as high quality
well they say what if it costs more for
the low quality candidates to go to
college
it might be more work for them is the
idea in this original paper
then maybe we can have a situation where
only high quality candidates will be
willing to put in the work to go to
college and so the diploma
isn't valuable to them because of the
knowledge they gained but rather
as a signal of their ability to you know
pass classes and things like that and so
people have applied that kind of
thinking to various things in the human
realm
um where people do things that are very
hard to do
and then it can become kind of a signal
of their abilities to others
i mean i guess in some sense it's
bringing into question what it means to
be
rational like the uh you know you're
rational in some
sense you're playing a game and you're
getting the reward that you want but it
leads to behavior that might from some
remove be perceived as less than
completely what we would like to aspire
to as rational beings
yeah so that's the really interesting
thing about this whole literature on
conflict of interest signaling and then
um using costs to you know
guarantee that signaling can happen and
this really relates also to
biology because people bring up the same
thing like
well you know a peacock tail maybe
is reasonable in some way if it can get
the peacock you know to mate
but it costs so much right it's a huge
expenditure of
protein it's hard to drag this thing
around
can that really be a reasonable
adaptation and i think it depends how
you're thinking about these things
i mean if you count your social
environment
as a legitimate part of your environment
then it's totally reasonable to expend a
lot of costs
to signal certain things about you that
are going to get you social benefits
um or in the case of the peacock you
know sort of uh reproductive benefits
and and i mean that's clearly true that
it is part of your environment right
that
i guess it's just you know well this is
why i'm a physicist because it's too
hard to disentangle all the different
factors that are that are going to enter
an equation like this
yeah but you you want to go even further
i mean i don't know how much of this
is uh is sort of standard lore but in
your
in your other book you talk about the
origins of inequality the origins of
unfairness and you you point out that we
can use
game theory to explain why uh
it might seem rational to do something
that ends up with a
deeply unfair division of labor in our
society
yeah so i mean i think this is important
to understand because i've seen
analyses before where people will say
something like this you know
if we look at bargaining games and
bargaining in a whole society
we should always expect to end up at a
fair outcome
because nobody's going to accept that
they
get an unfair amount and so they're just
going to refuse to play
and will end up with fairness um
now i think that analysis ends up being
a terrible kind of analysis
because people are rational given the
social situation they're in or they make
choices given the social situation
they're in
and this by the way really relates to
previous work by people like um
uh ann cudd and susan oaken um
so you can have these situations where
say you have
two identity groups these could be men
and women or maybe identity groups of
different races
and they're engaged in maybe some kind
of bargaining scenario you know
who has to pay more or less who gets the
really
prime jobs or not who can sit at the
front of the bus or has to sit at the
back of the bus
so there are these kind of bargaining
situations they engage in
and you can use evolutionary models to
show that you'll end up
at inequitable conventions a lot of the
time where one group's getting more
and one group's getting less but if you
look at the group getting less
at every stage of the way they were
changing like learning and adapting in
ways that made
completely perfect sense given the
situation they were in
so they're you know taking the best
behaviors they can
to get the best payoffs and outcomes
they can given the pressures they're
under
from another group and so is it is it
just
because you know from again from a sort
of physics perspective i think about
these in terms of landscapes of
you know energy landscapes and you sort
of fall to the valley of a minimum and
then you're
meta-stable there even though it's not
the lowest point where like there could
be some even better
vacuum that you just can't find is it is
it an accident of history
that you end up in this unequitable
inequitable
division or was this sort of um
more globally rational it's just sort of
an inevitable thing that some people are
going to get screwed by the system
well so here's the kind of dialectic i
go through
in this book you know i show that if you
take
cultural evolutionary models suppose you
have a group of people and they're all
bargaining with each other
well in these models most of the time
fair outcomes emerge
unless you split the group into
different identity groups and as soon as
you do that
you get inequality emerging and that
basically has to do with
this way of breaking symmetry as soon as
you have two groups
um you have these identity markers where
you can say well i'm type a
you're type b and type a's treat type
b's in this kind of way
um and so that allows inequality to
emerge now in those models it's just an
accident of history
there's nothing about either group that
makes one more or likely to get
better outcomes so in that case it
really is just this kind of
uh you know symmetry breaking type of
argument by random chance
these people were you know being more
aggressive in their bargaining early on
and these people less aggressive and
then they all learn to end up at this
kind of pattern where one group is
getting more
so i kind of start showing all right all
you have to do is break
into identity groups you already have
this happening
but then of course if we want to think
about
real cases or slightly more realistic
cases
there are often going to be certain
factors
that can help explain why one group or
another is going to end up with more in
bargains
so if we're thinking about gender facts
about like
physical sex differences are sort of an
important symmetry breaker
in determining uh who's going to end up
with
better outcomes if we think about
cultural groups or racial groups or
groups like this they're going to be
facts having to do with power
economic advantage maybe with minority
status all of which
might matter to which group ends up with
more or less when we come to sort of
conventional bargaining outcomes
yeah now i can imagine that um again the
messiness of the history is is really
crucial here but
i mean maybe it's worth digging in a
little bit into the
technicalities of this claim uh because
i remember i was struck by it in your
book that
just the existence of different
identification markers that say you're
in one group versus another
changes what the rational strategy is i
mean basically because
there's a new possibility opens up i
will have this strategy against members
of my group and this other strategy
against other people
exactly and so i think that the kind of
really
core i one of the most core interesting
observations to
communicate here is this thing where if
you think about
bargaining um you know if you and i are
engaged in a bargain
there are many different kind of
outcomes we can coordinate on ones where
i get less and you get more
ones where i get more and you get less
or ones where we kind of equally
split our resources so in models these
last type the equal split outcomes
are special because you and i can do the
exact same thing
and perfectly divide our resource so
it's a kind of special equilibria where
you're being fair to each other and
other philosophers like jason alexander
and brian skirms and economists like
peyton young
have used this to try to explain why we
have norms for justice and fairness
right
um so you have these symmetric
equilibria that emerge when you don't
have groups
and then when you just add identity
markers so that i can say well i'm this
type and you're that type a whole group
of new equilibria
become possible which are equilibria
where members of one group
get some amount more and members of the
other group some amount less
you literally can't evolve these in the
other kinds of models
but in models with groups not only can
you evolve that sort of equilibria but
they just kind
of pop out of the dynamics all the time
and this is
i mean you'd want to say it's a super
robust finding it sort of doesn't matter
how you do the model
you still get this happening because of
this new asymmetry where you're able to
identify
who's of what sort of group and then
treat them differently is it is it worth
actually sort of giving you details
about an example game in which this be
the case
yeah so the bargaining game is a perfect
example game so say we have a bargaining
game
where you and i are dividing something
like people often will say a pie
and let's say here are our strategies in
the game we could each ask for
a third a half or two-thirds of the pie
so that's a specific game we have our
strategies we have players
um if we imagine a population playing
this game if we have just a population
where
people don't have any special identity
you almost always get
everyone demanding one half or a lot of
the time
sorry is there a stipulation that if we
both demand two thirds then we get
nothing or something like that
oh sorry yes i should have been more
specific so in this game the payoffs are
that um you know you get what you
demanded as long as you don't demand too
much
so if we both demand two thirds we're
sort of pushing too hard and then we get
a poor payoff for pushing too hard
and so the equilibria of the game are
that
um we can either both demand half you
can get a third and i get two thirds
right or you can get two thirds and i
get a third
yeah i mean which is an interesting
point you know for those who are not
professional game theorists in the
audience like all three of those
possibilities
are technically speaking equilibria like
one is fair
50 50 but if if one person always asks
for two-thirds and the other one always
asks for one-third that also
satisfies the criteria for being a
stable uh
set of strategies for the game right and
if one person asks for 99
and one person for one percent that also
satisfies the criteria
for being a stable equilibria of the
game and then
so how does this change when you get
groups in there and so
yeah the idea is when you get groups the
fact that i know you're in one group and
i'm in another
can give me this extra information where
i can say well people in that group
always demand a third
so when i meet members of that group i
can demand two-thirds
right i can ask for more and the idea is
that
this kind of reasoning can actually help
us understand
for example uh how we divide up
household chores
i mean i think like you you're very
careful you said you know look there are
differences
physiologically between men and women on
average so that's
some part of the explanatory roles being
played by that but there's also
just this symmetry breaking that screws
some people over
yeah well so if we look culture to
culture um
there are cultures that have like pretty
gender egalitarian norms and conventions
um where you know there isn't a big
power imbalance between
men and women where there maybe isn't a
big difference in how much
labor they do altogether and then there
are cultures that are
much less gender egalitarian and so
part of the point here is that you know
these are conventions
that emerge in part due to chance or
you know almost random historical
factors or accidents of history
where we end up with groups that are
much more or much
less fair once we have a kind of
division into two genders
yeah and you make the point that um
i'm not quite sure how to put this but
they get baked in like
a tiny little variation in some initial
stage can lead to
huge imbalances down the road yeah part
of the point i make is something like
this
you know the sort of first most
important role that gender plays in many
societies is as a locus for dividing
labor
and division of labor is not as
important in modern societies as it used
to be
so we still divide labor you know if i
say who in that household
is cleaning the windows versus taking
out the trash
you'll make certain guesses based on the
genders of the people but if we look at
more traditional societies
it was completely necessary to divide
labor because there were so many
skilled tasks that required doing that
were very hard to learn to do
and so having a rule where it's
something like well women will always be
the ones who learn to make rope
men will be the ones who learn to fire
ritual pottery
women will be the ones to dig tubers men
will be the ones to build houses
really benefited groups and so
you see these kind of conventions
emerging
where gender becomes this really
important locus for
division of labor and once gender
becomes really important in determining
who's going to do what
it also then becomes important in
determining who's going to get how much
and who's going to deserve what and
that's in part because people get
different things based on what they're
doing you know the person who controls
food production
might you know be in a special position
within
a family or a society to kind of have
more for themselves demand more for
themselves
and then it's also just because now
you've kind of created
this meaningful social difference where
people can look at that difference and
be like well
we think that these kinds of people are
different than those kinds of people
these ones are the rope makers these are
the ritual pottery makers
the rope makers they're the kind that
deserve less than the pottery makers
and so you can have these kinds of
meanings and conventions attaching to
these categories
uh that emerge for other purposes
is it is it a slightly depressing
conclusion in the sense that
you know it was it was sort of not some
evil or unfairness in the hearts of
people that made this happen but it was
just the dynamics of evolution under the
constraints of rational game players
well i try to be really careful about
that
because there is evil in people's hearts
sometimes and there's a lot of
discrimination and there's a lot of
really morally wrong discrimination
and these results shouldn't be taken as
indicating that any of that is less
morally wrong than we thought before for
sure
but um i think part of the important
thing to realize
is that inequity kind of has a
life of its own or a tendency to arise
via very like non-offensive things
so if you have groups of people if you
have kind of social identity groups
within them
and if everyone tries to learn to do
what's best for them
inequity can just emerge from those
preconditions
which i think helps explain why it's
both
so common cross-culturally why you know
inequity based on
social identity is the rule not the
exception
but also tells us that um it's quite
likely to happen and should require
sort of active responses rather than
passive ones i mean
it won't you know i think there's kind
of an idea like in thinking about social
inequality like we'll keep trying to fix
it and then we'll get to a point where
it's fixed and then we're done
and i think this analysis says that's
not really the right way to think about
it
because these really basic forces having
to do with learning
and strategic interactions are going to
push us towards inequitable patterns
almost on their own
and so it's going to be the kind of
thing that you'll want to you'll have to
always be thinking about
always be actively addressing if you
don't want to have high levels of social
inequity
yeah so there is some i mean but that is
that that is the depressing part of it
uh
yeah well i mean there's this
it's almost saying that um
maybe it is saying that an unequal
division of
resources and rights and privileges in
society
is the natural thing it's not saying who
is supposed to be the winners and the
losers necessarily
but uh you know it's a rich get richer
kind of phenomenon
yeah well let's specify that when we say
natural we'd say something like
it is the thing that you know emerges
naturally right but we certainly
wouldn't want to give it like
the moral weight you know sometimes
people saying that's not the good thing
oh that's the good thing
right or we can't help that it's natural
uh and we we want to say one thing about
it
but not the other right i mean the flip
side is you can make an argument that
people shouldn't be uh as touchy or
defensive right you know about fixing it
you can just say look i'm not saying
that people were evil i'm just saying
there was evolutionarily
uh game theoretic dynamics going on and
we need to
actively take a role to counterbalance
that
i mean i think it should give us um you
know
some reason to think like and i don't
want to say this about
you know sort of every discriminatory
behavior but some sorts of
discriminatory behavior
some reasons to think like if i were in
that social position
i'd be behaving the same way potentially
right right
so like it it's weird to say
counterfactually if i had been a man
yeah
like a lot if i had been raised as a man
i think i very reasonably would have
learned all you know i would have been
socialized
to expect to get more than i'm
socialized to expect to get as a woman
and that would have been pretty natural
for me
and so it maybe gives some locus for
extending understanding to people who
are behaving in discriminatory ways
on on that kind of grounds i i mean that
might be something you could take away
from this
well and also just to go back to the
prisoner's dilemma you know and the idea
that if the two prisoners were
allowed to talk to each other and work
out a mutual cooperation strategy then
they would you know neither one of them
would defect and they would get the best
possible outcome
um in the real world we like to think
that
we can take this meta step back and be
rational and say like okay well
there was this natural dynamics that
ended us up in this equilibrium but it's
not
in some sense what we want or what we
value so let's take action against it
yeah and actually i think that's much
more plausible when it comes to
bargaining than when it comes to the
prisoner's dilemma so actually
in studies of the prisoner's dilemma
like people being able to talk can do
something beneficial for them
it does not guarantee that people don't
defect
with bargaining um it's different from
the prisoner's dilemma
in that there are all these different
equilibria right in the prisoner's
dilemma the only equilibrium
is the kind of bad one in the bargaining
game the fair outcome is an equilibrium
now just thinking like we can all sit
down and talk about what we want and get
something better
might not quite get us there because if
we think about an equilibrium say where
those in one social group are getting
more and the others are getting less
well the people getting more you know
it's really good for them to get more
and so just a conversation like hey
what's happening isn't fair
let's fix it up um may or may not
be persuasive and if you look at you
know what happens in the real world this
kind of outside model world now
often people engage in all sorts of kind
of
special thinking or reasoning to justify
why they ought to get more in a sort of
discriminatory
situation right to justify the status
quo that benefits them
and to have some reason why that should
be okay
so a discussion alone i have no idea we
were talking about i've never met people
who did that before this is
some weird philosopher's concoction that
i'm unfamiliar with
yeah let me make sure that i actually i
think i understand the point of the of
the bargaining game so
we're dividing the pie and and roughly
speaking um
if there's a known group of people who
have you know for whatever reason we
know ahead of time they're going to
demand two-thirds of the pie
and i meet one of these people then the
even though the equitable thing would be
for me to ask for
half the pie if i know they're going to
ask for two-thirds i actually come out
better
just by asking for one-third and that's
sort of the is that a
simplification but fair origin of this
bifurcation
yeah that's the right kind of thing i
mean you have a and you know
also sort of socialization over a
lifetime plays an important role you
come to expect these people are always
going to demand
a lot of me and if i want to get
anything i'm going to have to make a
concession right i'm going to have to be
accommodating
and so you learn to behave
accommodatingly towards some people
or in a more like demanding aggressive
way towards other people
um yeah and and the hope is
that the real world case is a little bit
less idealized than that and there are
people who all their lives
have been getting two-thirds of the pie
but if they
if you ask them they will say they're
big believers
in equitability and fairness and maybe
you can get them to switch their
strategy through hooker by crook
yeah and we certainly do see this happen
sometimes you know it's not the easiest
process
because i think there is some resistance
you know if you're getting all the good
stuff
why you know there's going to be some
resistance to going down to a half
but we do see these processes happening
where you know
like there are these
educational processes that make clearer
to men or clearer to white people like
you're getting too much
and you are also a person who holds to
fairness norms you know most of us are
in our society we think we ought to be
fair that that's the right thing
and so if you can really convince people
you are getting too much you're behaving
in a discriminatory way
sometimes it can change people's
behaviors
mean sometimes there's a very common
strategy uh that says look
just being fair to everyone helps
everyone right like you know
discriminating against women or
minorities or whatever is really hurting
society
as a whole but at least in principle
it's not necessarily true right i mean
it might just be there are finite
resources and they're being distributed
inequitably and
and we're making the big ask of asking
people or groups of people to say
give up some of what you have in the
name of fairness
i think that's very insightful and i
mean so i understand arguments like
feminism is for everyone and i think to
some degree there are truths to that
which have to do with things like um
the way people are constrained into
certain roles based on
their gender or even perhaps their race
like
you know if you're a man traditionally
you're not supposed to
love caring for an infant or spend a lot
of time with your infant right and so
that's a kind of harm to you that you're
being
taken away possibly from a role you
might really like to play
and so in that sense you know a movement
like the feminist movement
is for everyone but i i think it's
really too simple to say
fairness benefits all of us and it
ignores a lot of the reasons why
movements towards
fairness like civil rights movement or
black lives matter movement or feminist
movements
meet so much resistance because people
aren't dumb you know
i've been winning this game for years
for them
[Laughter]
well i mean okay maybe maybe we've
already answered this one but maybe just
to wrap things up
does this kind of analysis suggest
strategies
for making the world a more equitable
place i mean
i don't want to end on like saying well
it's just the law of nature that we got
we got to stick with it i mean we can
appeal to people's senses of fairness
but
uh can we in some sense change the game
that we're playing so that it just
becomes more rationally self-interested
for everyone to be more fair to each
other
good i mean so and i even though there's
some kind of like you know
depressingness of the lessons from this
book i certainly
also would like to emphasize like we see
cultures do better you know become
more fair and then we see across
cultures some cultures that are much
more fair than other ones
so it's not like it's just hopeless
right there are definitely ways
that groups of people can be better with
respect to equity
so thinking about like the modeling in
this book and some of the things it
tells us about doing that
and one thing that i think is kind of
important to realize
is that norms can be eroded
before you ever see change happening so
norms and conventions tend to be very
stable because if everyone in society is
adhering to them
there are these kind of forces having to
do with payoff that means
everyone else is kind of you know pushed
towards adhering to them
so if everyone in one group is demanding
two-thirds that makes it
you know there's always this force
pushing everyone in the other group to
demand one-third right
but you can have situations where people
stop liking a norm
before they stop adhering to it right
everyone's still doing it
but you can have people becoming
dissatisfied with it learning more about
it
coming to believe that it's in just
a related lesson to this is that you
don't see change happening until
actually people
change their behaviors right so you can
talk a lot but at the end of the day
you've got to do something different
for a norm to change and this can mean
people who are disadvantaged making
higher demands
and just messing things up for everyone
for a while till
everyone else suggests or it can mean
people in an advantage situation
conceding more
changing what they're demanding saying
i'm gonna give more
until uh we end up at a new norm you
usually see the first one more than the
second one
but so i think that's an important thing
to think about okay we can have
people changing their minds about things
but the behavior can still look stable
for kind of a long time
and then if we want real change to
happen someone has to actually
make that change like change their
strategy do something different
okay karl marx i thought that the
philosophers were just trying to
describe the world and here you are
suggesting that we actually try to
change it as well i mean that's a pretty
radical move
but i am hopeful i mean look i i i'll
tell you how much of an optimist i am
i like to think that uh these kinds of
analyses philosophical or biological or
whatever
actually do help change people's minds i
think it's very hard to tell
you know i think that the the effects of
new ways of thinking
are just so diffuse and so delayed in
their
impacts that you might never know but i
actually do think it matters
i hope you're right we'll do our part to
spread the word so
caleb thanks so much for being on the
mindscape podcast all right thanks for
having me sean
[Music]
you